hello my name is jose martin garcia and
i'm going to be talking about
uncertainty the representation and
propagation this is a new addition and
very useful for representation of
physical quantities and their errors
thank you for coming
it is being a physicist myself it is a
great pleasure for me to introduce the
concept of uncertainty in the warm
language this is a concept of broad
applicability in science and engineering
in research and industry there are many
reasons why when we have measurements
there can be uncertainty related to
complete definitions of what we are
measuring problems with some plain
repetition of soft sort of observations
and so this has been a long-standing
issue that for example in the bottom
alph database they have lots of data
that needs representation with errors so
it will be great to have this new object
so historically there has been always a
variety of methods to deal with
uncertainty and fortunately in the last
few decades there have been an effort to
organize the various methods and various
organizations of measurements for of
different countries have a grid or
document which is now very famous called
the gum document these is an
abbreviation for guide to the expression
of uncertainty in measurement so our
objective here is to do something which
complies perfectly to what this document
says this document has been produced by
this working group of metrology and the
current edition is of 2010 with minor
Corrections since then it's based on a
recommendation from 1980 and in fact
most of the main ideas the names etc
were already there in a one-page
document from nineteen
it 80 quite interesting the objectives
are to promote full information on how
uncertainty statements are arrived at
and to provide a basis for the
International comparison of measurement
results in a sense what the ice SI units
did for the measurement itself this
document tries to do for the
representation and treatment of
uncertainty so in this document they
start by trying to change some of the
nomenclature the tradition and
nomenclature so for example they insist
that error is not the right concept
because error is the difference to the
true value and when you measure
something you don't know the true value
so you shouldn't talk about errors this
is more about daily estimations so the
concept of uncertainty is more general
they they give this definition here and
certainty of measurement is the
parameter associated with the result of
a measurement that characterizes the
dispersion of the values that could
reasonably be attributed to the
measurement the measurement is the thing
we are trying to measure uncertainty is
a nice name then the traditional
distinction between statistical errors
and systematic errors is replaced by
these new names which are not so good
type A and type B but this is what they
suggested already in 1980 and this
working group has kept those names and
now books use those names as well
however this is about the origin of the
uncertainty in our representation we
will not care about where they find
certainty is coming from we care about
how to represent it and how to combine
it but not where it's coming from so
type A and type B is not going to be a
concern for us then they have a new word
for what is usually called propagation
and I still call propagation which is
combination so what we called error
propagation is now from uncertainty
combination and then there is a concept
of extent
uncertainty which I will mention in
passing its when we express
uncertainties with expressions like 3
Sigma instead instead of the standard 1
Sigma or 95 confidence level this sort
of thing so it's just an alternative way
of expressing the same uncertainty okay
so let's go for the main object being
introduced here this is this concept of
around so I have to start saying that
this is all experimental design it may
change and in particular because Steven
does is not very happy with the name
around this will probably change so it's
a very difficult we have we have been
considering lots and lots of names so so
we would love to hear if you prefer some
particular name or have suggestions so
ok so the basic object is this one
around and we have the value the best
value for a measurement let's say this
one and this is the uncertainty right so
automatically it will be represented
with a given number of significant
digits we will talk about that in the
next slide but the important thing to
realize is that internally it still has
all the digits we entered so that when
we do computations we are actually
handling all the digits to move we have
it just of for typesetting that we
choose a particular number of digits so
now if we do a square root of that for
example we will get the square root of
that and there will be the standard
propagation or combination of error and
still we have all the digits inside we
can do this with symbolic input so what
perhaps I should evaluate some of this I
think I have there this is in the
prototype kernel so far right so so we
can do the combinations and we can also
handle symbolic input just in case we
want to see which formulas we are being
we are using internally so something
something very simple so that would be
the
the formula for the uncertainty are or
linear standard linear propagation of in
a square root and of course if we now
replace the numbers that we had inside
we obtain the same value right that's
very simple that that's a basic idea so
we were talking about significant
figures so this is one of these points
in which there is no agreement of how
many difficult significant figures to
show so following the particle data
group which is again a big player in
this world of uncertainty we will follow
what is called the rule of three five
five this means that if we have we look
at the uncertainty even the first three
nandi nonzero digits of the uncertainty
are above three five five for example in
these cases is already one more 3 5 6
then we round to only one so we show
this as zero point four if the error is
three five five sir then certainty is
still five five or less then we show two
round to two which may be rounding up or
running down but we show two and on the
upper limit if we have 95 or more it
will be around two one if we have less
we will keep the one so so it's all
following the same rule so but this is
only for this play internally we are
keeping only this all the in all the
digits and we will be do doing all the
computations with these digits with all
the digits do we have right so at the
moment the 355 is hardwired but it will
be configurable in the future so the
choice of these three five five is in
order to not have too much of a change
when we have round in the uncertainty
for so for example going from 3 5 5 to
0.4 it's a 13 percent increase if we
chose for example our rule of 1 5 5
which is also chosen in some references
that will be and when
9% increase in the uncertainty that's
considered too much the value can be 1/2
can be negative can be as small as we
want even zero and we keep always the
same rules if this is 2/5 they will have
to digit and therefore this needs to
have the same number of digits to the
right of the decimal point okay that's
for now something very important is the
interaction with quantity because this
will be used a lot with quantities so
here we have quantities again we can do
operations and in this case we are
having around inside quantity so we that
means we have the same units for both
numbers we can have the opposite
direction in which we have around with
quantities inside and then we can have
different units right we can do
operations and doing the operations that
will probably mix together so because we
may not know which which units we want
to have they will get mixed in makes no
sense
you can also have mixtures of units
which are not based on base 10 so we
have this kind of situation for example
in which you have here one digit to the
right of the decimal point
okay you have to so that's because you
may have the situations like this in
which you have if you convert all to fit
then you keep two here because it's
consistent with two if you convert all
to inches you have one here and one
there so that's why in at the beginning
we have two here and one there so that
that's irrational and of course there
are standard compatibility checks of of
units as usual with quantities at the
moment we are handling relative
uncertainty VI scaled right so you
introduce scale this means five percent
error five percent uncertainty and this
will be converted into an absolute
uncertainty Oh
so let's go to the main part of this
propagation of uncertainty so if we have
an something that we recognize
immediately as a numeric function then
we will do the computation and have the
formula that is standard using the
standard Gaussian propagation so these
formulas remember are based on the
imputation of this object as if it was
the distribution a statistical
distribution this Gaussian with mean mu
and standard deviation Sigma and then
when you combine and do the proper
statistical operation then you get these
formulas which are a linear
approximation to two to the exact
formulas so for an arbitrary function
that we don't recognize as numeric this
doesn't do anything and now there is
here a new function it's currently
occurring around replace but again it's
not a very good name so yet it will do
the all the operations saying well you
take f of X and then X is actually has
value around mu with uncertainty Sigma
and then you will get the standard
formula right so the squares first
ordinal derivatives
except now this is all being done I
automatically for for the standard
operations subtraction addition etc so
this is the case of extraction with two
of them so we always have here the the
son in particular it will subtract
something from itself we get zero and
then we have this object here with a
square root of two we will discuss this
square root of two more carefully in a
moment so we have products we have
division first order division of powers
exit it's all very easy for basically
first order derivatives
what's the difference between X plus X
and 2x here we get different results why
what is the difference coming from right
because here so it's always to me as
best value but here we have square root
of 2 okay we have two so what is the
difference well here is where
correlation plays a big role and we have
to be careful about it
so if we we introduce here the notation
for replacement when we have a
multivariate case in which we have the
vectors variables X 1 X 2 and we have
the vector being mu1 mu2
best value and each one has its own
Sigma this is the case of independent
statistical random balance so we have
that result now this is equivalent to
this case so now here we are introducing
a covariance matrix instead of just the
diagonal we introduced the covariance
matrix we get the same result but now
this notation allows us to introduce
correlation right so in this case for
example winter we say that the two
variables are correlated so now have
these two terms of the yagna and this we
get this new result with a larger
uncertainty right and now yes so this
case is where we replace the Meuse now
we get the factor 2 instead of the
factor square root of 2 that we had
original right so this is the case in
which so the two means correlation so in
that respect what was happening here is
that we were considering this X and this
X or rather this around and the other
around has independent statistical
objects right and while in this case is
it just twice the same so we get two
instead of factor of square root of 2
the case of two variables is especially
important in the literature and so it
has its own notation with a correlation
factor Rho here right which has values
from minus one to plus one so this is
the case and we see here how if the
correlation is zero then this is 0 then
we have our square root of 2 if the raw
parameter is 1 then we can have a square
total complete square and then we have a
2 in front of Sigma so that's the
important of correlation and then
another way of looking at correlation is
like this which is an example I took
from another standard reference which is
Taylor's book so imagine that you have
these two rules of replacement P is
going to be a nested and certain time
variable with best value p0 and Delta PS
uncertainty same for Q and I just have
this simply simplification function
saying well everything is real very
simple so this is the correct result if
we do the computation now can we just
use replace all as usual well the answer
is no if we just did replace all we
would get a completely different result
and you see this is a sum of squares sum
of positive variables so of positive
objects so there are more terms here
which are not present here so what's
wrong out here the difference is that of
course again we are considering that
this P and this P are independent but we
are they are not because they are in the
same formula so if we write this
expression as this other expression in
which P and Q appear only one then we
can do the computation will replace all
and we you see we get the correct result
and not this one so again this is a
problem of correlation who could express
yes we could express the correlation
like saying P 1 P 2 but P 1 and P 2 are
fully collected and then we would get
the correct result so this is another
example of how correlation is very
important when we do
competitions the gamma document gives a
variety of examples just to make sure
that we are all understanding what's
going on and I just took one of them the
first one they say take these six
variables and let's compute this formula
and you see some of them are replay are
repeated like alpha s or theta s
etcetera so they give them a bunch of
information about what's the actual and
certain objects we are measuring so we
have for example this one so I'm going
to create a rule for each of them then
some of them come frog for example for
from fittings so we take the mean and
then the test the deviation of the mean
is the deviation divided by the square
root of the number of measurements this
is a way of adding new sources of
uncertainty this is the number coming
from confidence level three again again
and again so these are the evaluation
values of the uncertain objects as I
said we don't care about where they are
coming from we just care about how to
merge them and now after a couple of
pages in which they do very careful slow
computation they arrive at this result
I'm copying the final statement here
right so we can do that with a round
replace which will take care of
correlations and everything all at the
same time and we arrive at the exact
same result they give they don't like
the plus/minus notation and they prefer
to write everything words as here but we
still keep the plus/minus notation
okay so that was an example now how can
we do better well first as I said this
is based on Gaussian propagation linear
Gaussian propagation so a way in which
we can do better is first by including
higher order terms so this is the
standard formula for linear propagation
in which we only handle first order
derivatives now we can do better and
include second order derivatives just in
case we are working with a function in
which for example the first order
derivative vanishes and then we need to
go to higher orders or for some reason
this has a specially large value and you
know we need to handle it so just to
show you a comparison with with the
statistical functions this is the
equivalent of transforming a normal
distribution with the square and we can
check that this result and this result
are equivalent with the statistics we
can also compute skewness and higher
moments here we will see in a moment
that we can do that as well here the
difference is that in the statistical
transformation this is all done exactly
here we are always using Taylor's
functions so that we can do more cases
but there will always be an
approximation to a given order this is
exact because we are using a polynomial
yes so this is showing that if we add
zero here it means well we are worrying
about the skewness well this was the
mean this was the variance or standard
deviation and this is now the third
argument allow you to express skewness
enjoy in your original distribution for
their measurements
okay now we can go to higher orders as
well including skewness and this will be
the formula and you can go up to order
four and I have her wired all the
formulas up to order four including
correlation this is an example the
professor or France or suggested
yesterday which is let's do division
with two variables and let's have
correlation and do it to second order
and that would be the result and for
example the gum document in the examples
we did they they say here well what
would it is fine but actually there are
some terms that are important at second
order so let's do them as well and then
they have many more computations here
right so with around replace we can just
put a two here and they resolve which
they say well the result changes from 32
to 34 nanometers well we just guessed
here the 34 just by changing here to two
very quickly we can handle a asymmetric
uncertainty so we have plans very
different from the - value this is the
left one this is the right one and we
can do competitions again as you sir and
what's going on here basically is that
we are doing separate computation for
the left hand side and the right hand
side of the interval and just to show
how we can have seen 0.4 on the left 0.7
on the right and that explains these two
different values here the 1.6 the 2.8
then some of the original functions have
been already extended to handle around
so and here you see we have done this
one generating random values of around
and so we can have something like that
or least line plot with joining those
values or bar charts etc -
okay and in my last minute I will just
talk about new things that we want to do
here so we need a native understanding
of coverage factors like what you say
three Sigma or confidence levels going
to say 95 percent consider confidence
level so we need a way of expressing
that directly inside around and I will
know what to do we need to see how to
treat complex numbers and the fact that
typically the real and imaginary parts
are correlated because you do operations
and they're rotating in complex space
and so they get correlated we also want
to extend these two dates in the same
way that it interfaces now with
quantities we want it to interface with
dates so we can talk about dates which
are kind of fuzzy not fully specified
and of course this needs to be
propagated through the system and parts
of the system that worry about
uncertainty like fitting functionality
etc as I said if you have criticisms
comments or suggestions about more
things that this should do places you
want to use it or suggestions for names
please let us know thank you
[Applause]